I the one thing I want to kind of
break down is the science on why the
number one complaint I've been getting
from listeners and you've been getting
from listeners your whole your whole
career why is it every time I hear the
[__] radio it's the same [__] 10
songs now there is a science to this but
that's that I'm sure that that's been
the feedback for however many years you
guys play the same [__] you guys play
the same [__] yeah break down from Doc
winner the science of why a radio
playlist is very tight and why you might
hear five or six songs over and over
again if you listen all day driving an
Uber or something I like to use the
analogy of a nightclub
um our job is to retain listeners right
let's say if you were in a nightclub and
the DJ decided he wanted to go off on a
rant and play
you know 30 minutes of Frank Sinatra or
whatever clear to dance floor clear the
dance floor they probably stay and wait
until he got came back to his senses
doesn't happen in radio they go find the
other
they go they may not come back I've
actually been in the car and and not in
the case of uh of playing bad music but
a very long commercial break and saw
this Uber driver listening to us
you know go to the competition
obviously he was preferred us come back
we were still playing commercials and I
could see his anger
I'm gonna go back there instead because
you know and what retains them is a
record that they like that they can sing
not necessarily something they've never
heard you know right I think so I always
tell people it's like the average radio
listeners how how many minutes a day
might be 10 15 minutes so if you think
about it in that through that lens we
have we talked about PPM the meters are
like people get paid to wear these
little pagers and it tracks their
real-time listening so it's like you're
hoping to play something to keep
somebody around in that 10 minute window
that they happen to listen yeah so the
research and data on how you come up
with what the five powers are what all
goes into that
probably the most important thing is
um who you're going to ask
you know do you like this record you
know who's your screen is what they call
you know it might be
18 to 34 year old women it could be 18
and 34 year old man it could be 18 or 34
year old
black women 18 to 34 year old Latino
women and as a programmer you got to
know what you're talking you know what
moves the needle in your market for your
demo you know 18 to 34 Latino females
who listen to radio three hours you can
get that granular with it
um
and then you begin to understand you
know what moves the needle from the for
them the more you listen to
um the more you do research and the more
you ask the right questions you get a
sense of okay like this is what moves
the needle for them and then you you
give people what they want to keep
coming back you ever go to a restaurant
and all of a sudden they tell you oh we
stopped making your favorite meal I just
had just happened making my favorite
meal wow yeah we got bored with it just
happened come on man
yeah so
um I mean that's the science and again
it can be frustrating for people but you
know again and there's a bunch of
factors right you'll have like call out
which is where you're pretty much kind
of is that a how would you describe call
out for a radio station you call out to
people that fit the screen and you play
hooks of songs you can ask what do you
think of this song what do you think of
this song yeah you'll see streaming data
for the market yeah you check Shazam
so uh and then there's also the M scores
which is is that something you guys you
obviously M scores is like I look at it
but you know somebody could have turned
the song off you don't really know what
the reason is and that's what the
switching score is someone turned off
the song or a number of people turned
off the song
while I was playing
um and sometimes you can look at the
song and say okay you see other factors
that contribute to you know might be the
wrong time of day you play the song it
might just be tired of it right or rest
it and then test it again is what we
like to say but